I wrote a Blog now there's a movie being
made starring Meryl Streep and Amy Adams
how do you process that
sort of ratcheting up for a couple of
years now is oh I have a Blog oh I have
a book oh someone wants to make a movie
oh my God nor Efron wants to make a
movie you know so so now we've got to
hit the top one and and Meryl Streep
Julie Powell the inspiration behind
2009's Julie and Julia has died she was
49 years old
[Music]
all right note on dealing with live
lobster Amy Adams brought Julie's story
to life on the big screen playing the
civil servant turned self-taught cook
opposite Meryl Streep's Julia Child when
they came with Amy Adams I mean you
can't do better than Amy man I mean
she's just so tiny was what the only
surprise to me but she's such a lovely
wonderful actress and I've been so
thrilled and honored that anyone would
even think that that she equals me in
any way shape or form Powell's husband
Eric confirmed the news of her death to
the New York Times she died at their New
York home of cardiac arrest and I'd
always love to cook and I'd always
wanted to write so it sort of came
together as a sort of Reese's Peanut
Butter Cup moment Powell began blogging
her attempt to cook all 524 recipes in
Julia Child's mastering the art of
French cooking in one year back in 2002.
three years later those blogs became
this book which became Nora ephron's hit
movie in 2009 my mother made buffignon
but it wasn't just it was Julia's
and it was like she was there like Julia
was there
in the room
on our side like some great big good
fairy Powell's second book cleaving a
story of marriage meat and Obsession
came out the same year I've always found
that when you're stuck and you're in a
rut you have to do something crazy
that's just for you and it doesn't have
to make any sense it doesn't have to
make any sense to anyone else and if
everyone is telling you that's crazy
don't do that that you may be on to
something she survived by her husband
her brother and her parents
foreign
[Music]